watch your job Maxine Waters wants to
impeach every Republican from president
to dog catcher the NFL and Nike continue
to get woke and go broke
despite fake news to the contrary though
they both are getting some unlikely
financial help from President Trump we
will explain then after another knife
attack in Paris on Sunday night we asked
on this anniversary of 9/11 has the West
learned anything in the 17 years since
those awful attacks finally John Bolton
defends the nation state while Democrats
promise to tear it down
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today first I have got
to thank a sponsor lending a club oh is
Lending Club good for decades credit
cards have been telling us buy it now
pay for it later and then they charge us
that crazy high interest that gets out
of control fast I'm telling you if you
have an unexpected improvement you got
to make around the house
I remember this houses are always
breaking down they're just a money pit
or you want to pay off some very high
interest credit card debt you should do
it the smart way and use Lending Club
because you have really lowered those
interest rates since 2007 Lending Club
has helped millions of people regain
control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to a bank no high interest credit
cards just go to Lending Club com tell
them about yourself and how much you
want to borrow pick terms that are right
for you and if you're approved your loan
is automatically deposited into your
bank in as little as few days this is
helpful for me because Ben doesn't pay
me it's the number one peer-to-peer
lending platform of over 35 billion in
loans issued go to Lending Club comm
slash Knowles Cana wles check your eight
minutes borrow up to 40 G's Lending Club
comm slash Knowles keno wles
borrow up to $40,000 Lending Club
dot-com / Knowles all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
okay there is so much to get to today on
the 17th anniversary of 9/11 and and a
lot actually in political news that ties
into that both internationally and at
home from the Trump administration so
but before we get into that because I
really want to spend some time going
into what we've learned in the last 17
years this is a very emotional day for a
lot of New Yorkers I'm a New Yorker for
a lot of Americans before we go into
that into the analysis of the day want
to run through the political news
because there's still a lot of that
going on and sometimes politicians tried
to hide a little political and campaign
actions in a bigger news cycles like
this so you know in politics the squeaky
wheel gets the grease and the squeakiest
wheel in our politics is probably Maxine
Waters if I couldn't I can't tell I
think she's the squeakiest wheel in the
Democratic Party so this came out
yesterday we talked about it a little
bit at the end of the show Maxine Waters
has her strategy for the midterm
elections here she is and I said if you
see
anyway just tell them you're not welcome
here anyway they say Maxine please don't
say impeachment anymore and when they
say that I say impeachment I think
that's because that's all Maxine Waters
can say his impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachment and I'm starting
to get the feeling it correct me if I'm
wrong I'm starting to get the feeling
that Maxine Waters doesn't like
Republicans very much you'll remember
Maxine Waters
very famously or infamously said when
all of these Democrats were going out
harassing Republicans members of the
Trump administration
she said you bet you better go harass
them go harass them at restaurants go
arrest them at the bank go arrest them
when you see them on the street and
she's doubling down on that here she's
saying absolutely go out there and
harass them later on in that in that
fundraising speech she said I wasn't
threatening Trump supporters there but I
threatened them all the time I
threatened them all the time so this is
her strategy going into the midterms
impeachment impeachment impeachment and
I actually can sort of understand this
strategy because what they're saying is
well we can't really run on policy the
policies are all going very well so what
we're gonna do is run on the personal
grotesqueness of the president we're
gonna say you don't want him to be the
president anymore
so elect us and we'll impeach him
because if the Democrats get a majority
in the House they're going to impeach
the president if they get a majority in
the Senate or a big majority in the
Senate then they'll convict the
president and remove him from office
okay so that I can sort of see how that
works but the reason that I think
Democrats are actually running a little
scared here that maybe that generic
ballot for the midterm elections is not
going as well for them as all of the
expert pollsters are telling us that it
is is because of this next strategy they
keep calling for the removal of from
office of the president for the 25th
amendment because the president is
apparently crazy here's Sarah Sanders
addressing this issue it's the president
make of all of this talk of the 25th
amendment
and some of what he hears on media
outlets regarding the word crazy talk
there's a lot of it seems like there's a
lot of talk about that many of the
mainstream media I think we would say
that it's about as ridiculous as most of
Bob Woodward's book the fact that that's
actually being honestly discussed is
ridiculous and frankly it's insulting to
the nearly 62 million people that came
out and overwhelmingly supported this
president voted for him supported his
agenda and are watching and cheering on
as he successfully implements that
agenda every single day so the 25th
amendment is that if the president is
incapacitated physically or mentally
incapacitated you can remove him from
office and I gotta ask if the Democrats
are talking about this if they're saying
we need to invoke the 25th amendment Bob
Woodward book the press corps in the in
front of Sarah Sanders the press corps
being the communications wing of the
Democrat Party
if these elected Democrats are talking
about this then do they really think
their electoral chances are that good
because if if I thought that I were
gonna win an election then I would say
we'll get rid of him when I win the
election if I didn't think I were gonna
win an election then I'd be talking
about 25th amendment it seems to me
they're tipping their hand a little bit
they're kind of showing maybe things
aren't as strong as everybody wants to
pretend they are because you know it was
all of the experts in 2016 who told us
Hillary is going to win he'll 99% chance
Hillary is going to win polls coming out
the night before analyses of of
meta-analyses of polls of polls saying
it's guaranteed they're gonna the
Democrats are going to win don't even
show up to vote Republicans and then
what happened it was a pretty pretty
landslide victory in the electoral
college
so we hear Maxine Waters saying run
impeachment impeachment impeachment you
know there's supposed to be a legal
basis of impeachment you have to charge
the president with a crime and so far
they haven't done that collusion is not
a crime they don't we don't even see
evidence of collusion there's not you
know sending mean tweets is not a crime
be not being very nice to Joe
Scarborough and Mika Brzezinski that's
not a crime so they should provide a
crime but even if not even if it's just
a purely political matter if if they
thought they were gonna win they just
on that I don't I don't see it and by
the way I don't know if the Democrats
know this if you impeach Donald Trump
then you get Mike Pence do they like
Mike Pence what are they gonna do when
Mike Pence comes around he's a very
normal conservative he doesn't tweet all
the time
he's an indiana conservative maxine
waters actually provides the answer on
what they're gonna do if they finally
get there which they impeach donald
trump here is what they will get with
president pence and so we have a
responsibility to continue I had a
conversation here today when someone
asks but what about this if you were
able to impeach this will be worse and I
said look one at a time we can be made
to fear anybody who would undermine our
ability to have a decent quality of life
oh they're just gonna get pence to okay
they're just gonna get him to they're
just wait your turn now then we'll get
him to listen to how Maxine Waters
projects here because what she's calling
for is lawlessness Maxine Waters has
always called for lawlessness so she
said you know you've got to go harass
them in the street get in their face
harass their children harass their
families but then she says we will not
be intimidated you you're the one who's
calling for people to go harass the
families of elected Republicans and
appointed Republicans you're the one
who's saying go out in the street and
you're the one who's saying use the
mechanisms of our Constitution to remove
people that we don't like from office
even if they haven't committed a crime
just lawlessly remove the president and
then we'll remove the vice president
what are we going to accuse the vice
president of the worst thing they've
been able to accuse Mike Pence of is
only having dinner with his wife the
worst thing they've been able to accuse
Mike Pence of is being too good a
husband it's unbelievable in the
projection is so loud at this point in
the election at this point before the
midterms
she said Maxine Waters said right there
we will not allow anybody to interfere
with our good quality of life to stop us
from having a good quality of life I
live right near Maxine Waters this
district Maxine Waters has a very good
quality
she has people who aren't from
California maybe don't know that Maxine
Waters so she represents South LA
Inglewood all these pretty bad poor
neighborhoods but she had live there of
course she doesn't live there Maxine
Waters has a pretty nice quality of life
she has a house that's worth millions of
dollars I've heard estimates up to four
and a half million dollars a punch above
the average home price down in South LA
down in Dunn and Inglewood she has a
perfectly fine quality of life but she's
she's always projecting this she's
saying they're intimidating us they're
preventing us from our quality of life
when the the Democrats in this election
are accusing the Republicans of
something you can know that they've done
it in spades you can you know that
they've done it at a much higher rate
much more frequently so that's what
Maxine Waters and the Democrats are
doing what is Donald Trump doing Donald
Trump is doing exactly what we elected
him to do I'm not just talking about fix
the economy create jobs I am talking
about the actual reason we elected
Donald Trump which is to troll the
entire left here is a video that Donald
Trump released from his Instagram
account just last night because some of
those jobs of the past are just not
going to come back and when somebody
says he's gonna bring all these jobs
back well how exactly are you gonna do
that what are you gonna do what magic
wand do you have we've created more than
400,000 that's very soon we're gonna do
600,000 many effects of your growth
during the Trump years has been much
more robust this year we should get up
here 3% that would put us about 50%
above mr. Obama's performance the
economic boom continues it's the big
story of 2018 job growth wages but even
much better net more than four million
jobs created since the election wages
are growing at the fastest pace
decades more Americans are now employed
than ever before in the recorded history
of our country the list goes on and on
new policies are working all right
I just love so the video obviously is a
great it's this beautiful troll and it's
defensive by the way it was Barack Obama
who has been saying all of these things
he was saying you know Donald Trump he's
just terrible he's just you know he's
degrading our politics he's Nate doesn't
get credit for the economy so what does
Donald Trump do he comes back and hits
him and I'll I'll show why it is so
important because it highlights a true
fact of our economy but first before we
get to that I have got to thank a battle
box a brand new sponsor and oh is battle
box terrific battle box so this is just
this is like pure guy stuff I guess
women can like it too because they've
got all this camping gear but when I I
just open up this box here and it was I
got knives I got fire I got you know I
got all of these really cool things that
you can go out for survivalism for
camping and most subscription boxes
they're full of samples and junk you'll
never use but battle box is full of
solid gear for adventure seekers
survivalists and outdoor enthusiasts
this stuff is really really cool battle
box is your monthly subscription for
hand-picked outdoor survival everyday
carry gear go to try battle box calm
slash Knowles and I've you've got to pay
careful attention here TR y ba TT l bo
XCOM slash knowles k no w le s no e in
battle box pick the box you want this
start at just 25 bucks a month they
release a video for each new box so you
can see what's coming they've shipped
over half a million boxes it is great
right now our listeners get a free
tactical knife when you sign up for your
first battle box at try battle box comm
slash knowles try battle box calm slash
knowles get your first battle bucks plus
a free tactical knife a try battle box
be a TTL bo XCOM slash anoles KO w el e
s it is super cool and we've just been
running around the daily wire office
with knives so the video wouldn't have
worked if President Trump didn't have
the goods to back it up
he does have the good so you get both
aspects of it I'm so pleased that
Republicans are finally using humor
again it's been probably since Ronald
Reagan Republicans haven't really used
humor at the federal level but he's
going he's saying look this guy
whomp-whomp he told us it couldn't
happen all the experts said these jobs
are gone they're never going to come
back and the experts have a lot of
opinions that often aren't true we'll
talk about that certainly when we
reflect on September 11th and we reflect
on ambassador Bolton's comments
yesterday on the International Criminal
Court but just look at look at the
economy all around a small business
optimism is the highest since the Reagan
administration the NFIB small business
optimism index is at the highest level
that we have ever recorded and it's not
just going to the very tippy tippy top
of the socio-economic ladder it's
actually affecting blue-collar jobs this
is really important this is the first
time in a long time
we're seeing jobs in goods producing
industries mining construction
manufacturing they grew tremendously
over the past year three point three
percent this also is the best rate since
1984 since the Reagan administration
they told us if President Trump were
elected the economy would implode that
the markets would crash the jobs are all
gone they're not coming back
they're not coming back Donald there but
they are there they're growing and
growing that is a great thing which
makes me think from the mouth of Nancy
Pelosi herself that Democrats in their
heart of hearts actually think President
Trump is going to win they actually
think that he's going to survive because
Nancy Pelosi gave her party some hope
within the last few days she said oh we
need some new blood we need some new
blood but there was an important caveat
Nancy take it away I do agree that it's
time for new blood and we should move on
and Hillary Clinton had won and this
Affordable Care Act was protected I feel
very proprietary about that I was happy
to go my way we didn't know who would
come forward but that's up to the caucus
they give me the honor of serving and
it's up to them to choose who it comes
next Oh but to have no woman at the
table and to have the Affordable Care
Act at risk I said as long as he's here
I'm here you catch that as long as he's
here I'm here it sounds like Nancy
is betting on president from being here
for a while because that is her that is
her play right now she say as long as
he's here I'm here
she needs a foil the Democrats need a
foil the American people want the TV
show to keep going on so they can talk a
good talk he's out the generic poll
impeachment impeachment I think that the
Democrats are betting on Donald Trump
staying in office for a long time and
speaking of bad Democrat plays in recent
weeks they've somehow managed to turn
against the American flag this is true
in we see this especially in the
National Football League but we see a
threat Corporate America and we see it
among Democratic candidates so you
remember we talked about this NFL
kneeling for the flag drama now for two
years and in May of this year the NFL
came out and they said no more kneeling
no more kneeling you can't kneel it's
creating too much distraction the NFL
ratings had been tanking they were down
8% in 2016 when this all started they
fell ten percent last year analysts are
predicting that they'll fall even more
this year so they say oK we've got to
stop doing this and make no more
kneeling but then the politically
correct crowds the left came out and
said how dare you how do we're gonna do
and what are you how are you gonna
police this and buh-buh-buh-buh-buh so
then in July right after they announced
the policy in July they come out and say
well maybe there can be kneeling so what
they said well maybe we won't enforce
the policy we don't know how we're going
to enforce the policy so what you get is
more and more confusion over the weekend
we saw this come to fruition there were
two people in the NFL who kneeled for
the national anthem now that's that's
not so bad
2016 13 games I think over the weekend
lose these two guys Miami Dolphins Kenny
Stills and Albert Wilson but what that
really means even though it's just two
guys this is gonna keep going on it's
gonna keep going on and on and on the
right obviously is bashing this this is
a very bad thing they're protesting the
American flag symbol of our country and
the left is embracing this so the part
of me that is like earnestly taking in
this information says this is a horrific
thing to do the political cynical side
that little that little devil voice up
there says this is terrific news for
conservatives the
terrific news for Republicans because
we've somehow gotten the left and the
Democrats to protest the American flag
itself
I wonder if this whole protest wasn't
just started by some slick Republican
operative Roger stone or Paul Manafort
or somebody we have right now elected
Democrats applauding the flag protest
Ayanna Presley running for Congress in
Massachusetts is applauding this a beta
O'Rourke in Texas let pronounce that
wrong was that beta I think it's beta
O'Rourke in Texas is applauding this it
would the only thing that we could do
that might be more effective is to get
Democrats to protest apple pie that's
gonna be the next we're gonna say you
know for social justice you really ought
to protest apple pie I'll say yeah ate
apple pie Apple buys the worst because
polls show that the Americans hate this
protest you know and now Nike has made
this protest the face of their
advertising Colin Kaepernick is now
their advertiser there was a there was
this after Kaepernick became the
spokesman and the big image for Nike
there was a poll conducted by morning
consult sure that Nikes net favorability
had fallen 34 points because of the move
Republican among Republicans the
favorability fell 70 points but across
all sectors had fell and then in the key
demographics that Nike cynically thought
it was going to boost by this there was
no change in if anything there was a
slight decline in favorability that
includes younger generations Nike users
black customers and others they
cynically thought they were going to win
over those key demographics and it
didn't happen obviously the NFL ratings
have been falling and falling and the
one aspect of this that the left is
pointing out they say Nikes sales were
up over the weekend over Labor Day
weekend that's true but Nike sales are
always up over Labor Day weekend they
were up over Labor Day weekend last year
as well they were up more this year but
perhaps that's because the Trump economy
is up our economy is jumped dramatically
in the last year were a record high
economic growth and so it just gets back
to the flag and the left is saying oh
he's not protesting the flag he's
protesting police brutality he's
protesting the flag he says he's
protesting the flag here's Kaepernick in
his own words when there's significant
change and I feel like that flag
represents was supposed to represent
this country is representing
people the way they're supposed to toss
them it's the flag it's about the flag
he says it's about the flag if if he
were protesting police brutality he
could protest a police department if you
were protesting some specific policy he
could go outside the government office
and protest the policy or protest
Congress but he's protesting the flag
and that is horribly offensive because
the flag represents the country the flag
is the symbol of the country in this
country is the greatest country in the
history of the world
that's not chauvinism that's not just my
own bias that's not just because I was
born here it is the greatest country in
the history of the world and Americans
find this very offensive when you
disrespect the country because of all
the sacrifices Americans have made and
no time is this clearer then on
September 11th the the greatest country
in the history of the world learned a
real lesson 17 years ago and we look
around us now and we see that just on
Sunday night in Paris there was another
knife attack there's a knife attack by a
young Afghani man the authorities are
saying it wasn't terrorism or they're
not willing to call it terrorism but
there have been many other knife attacks
this year that we know our terrorism
that have been claimed by Isis just in
Paris just in Paris alone so 17 years
after September 11th has anything
changed has anything changed in global
politics in domestic politics in our
relations to one another since 9/11 2001
there have been seven attacks on the
United States by Islamic terrorists well
I think sometimes we think there haven't
really been any because 9/11 was so
traumatizing to so many people but there
were attacks at Fort Hood the Boston
Marathon Chattanooga killed four Marines
one Navy sailor San Bernardino pulse
nightclub on and on many of these
attacks claimed by Isis are done in the
name of Isis in the European Union just
since 2014 there have been 65 attacks
just since 2014 the last four years so
it seems like not a lot has changed
we're getting all of these attacks again
and again year after year after year
I remember 9/11 pretty well even though
I was very young I was 11 years old on
September 11 so I was in my sixth grade
classroom in New York
a lot all of our parents basically most
of our parents worked in the city I was
up in the suburbs and I remember it
clearly
I remember the strongest memory I have
of that day was President Bush sitting
in the Oval Office addressing the nation
that night and he articulated perfectly
what we all were feeling good evening
today our fellow citizens our way of
life our very freedom came under attack
in a series of deliberate and deadly
terrorist acts the victims were in
airplanes or in their offices
secretaries businessmen and women
military and federal workers moms and
dads friends and neighbors thousands of
lives were suddenly ended by evil
despicable acts of terror the pictures
of airplanes flying into buildings fires
burning huge huge structures collapsing
have filled us with disbelief terrible
sadness and a quiet unyielding anger
disbelief terrible sadness and a quiet
unyielding anger that is precisely what
New York felt that day it's precisely
what the rest of America felt that day
it's what we still feel I've never heard
anyone articulate that feeling better
than President Bush did in that speech
because I think a lot of times what we
hear is we shouldn't feel that anger
anymore oh let's let the anger go away
and let's just you know let's just come
together and okay it's not let's don't
be angry but a lot of us feel that today
and a lot of us feel that today because
justice still has not been fully
completed there are five animals sitting
down at Guantanamo Bay right now five
animal terrorists who participated in
that attack they have not been tried
it's been battled around it are they
going to be tried and at what time obey
are they gonna be tried in Manhattan
they're they're gonna be back and forth
and back and forth they need to be
swiftly tried and executed and the
President Trump could do a great service
to the matters of justice if
were able to hasten that along because
we still feel that anger we still feel
that justice hasn't quite been done you
know that sense of justice is what
President Bush showed us on the pile a
Ground Zero on after September 11th
he showed us that sense that feeling of
justice and I that this is I think the
one silver lining that we might have out
of this here's President Bush famously
with his bull
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know the rest of the world hears you
and the people who knocked these
buildings down will hear all of us soon
I can hear you the rest of the world
hears you and the people who knock this
building down these buildings down will
hear from all of us soon
what a beautiful sense of justice that's
why you got those cheers that days we
were all begging for them we're still
begging for them that there is a
satisfaction to that anger that
unyielding anger that we all felt and
that satisfaction will be completed
injustice that's what satisfies that
anger but we were talking the other day
we were reminiscing over the September
11th attacks some some friends around
here in the office and we said was there
any silver lining to that storm cloud
was there anything good that came out of
it is there anything we can say well
that's a consolation and there were a
few things the country was unified after
September 11th for about five minutes it
didn't last very long but it was unified
America really did come together New
York came together the rest of the
country came together Democrats and
Republicans came together after
September 11th I wish it had lasted
longer but that was a real achievement
the other is is patriotism they're there
and sacrifice and the great sacrifices
of the heroes not only of that day
though there were many heroes that day
on September 11th first responders
people on the airplanes there were many
heroes there but there were many heroes
afterward who enlisted who went overseas
and fought to defend our freedom many
gave the ultimate sacrifice many others
came back with wounds mental and
physical that sacrifice for my freedom
of yours that's a beautiful thing that
also came out of that day that we're all
very grateful for on an international
political level on the level of
statecraft is there anything good that
came out of it we look at all of these
attacks that are still happening we
might think not quite but there was
something that we learned which is the
lie of globalism and by global globalism
goes by many names we hear globalism
with your globalization we hear the New
World Order we hear the international
order or whatever the lies of that we're
exposed that day a National Security
Advisor John Bolton showed us that just
yesterday not coincidentally on the eve
of September
because it show he showed the American
people what happened the rest of the
world what happens when you try to
infringe on American freedom and on the
sovereignty of the United States and
this was the question what is the best
form of government what is the best way
to order our world but before September
11th 2001 we had been told from all
experts across the political spectrum
that history was over history is over
the nation-state is over we're moving
into a period of perpetual peace and
prosperity a new world order that we
heard it in that essay from Francis
Fukuyama the end of history he wrote
quote what we may be witnessing is not
just the end of the Cold War or the
passing of a particular period of
post-war history but the end of history
as such that is the endpoint of
mankind's ideological evolution and the
universalization of Western liberal
democracy as the final form of human
government has there been any more
triumphant triumphalist statement than
that we'll get into what that means and
what we learned 17 years ago about that
new homogenous universal state but first
I've got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube if you're on Facebook and
YouTube I'm shocked that you haven't
been censored yet go over to Daily wire
calm it is 10 bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you will get me you'll
get the intro Clavin show you get the
Ben Shapiro show you test questions in
the mailbag you get to hurry up on that
because the mailbag is gonna be on
Thursday most importantly you get the
leftist tears tumblr you saw Maxine
Waters you saw Colin Kaepernick you saw
Nancy Pelosi it is filling up left and
right these days so go over there and
get it's the only fda-approved vessel
for your delicious leftist ears go over
there right now and we will be right
back
we were told that history was over and
then we learned it wasn't true history
wasn't over no matter how much we said
it hey not everybody had to listen to us
we so often here in in the United States
that some people are on the right side
of history some are on the wrong side of
history Barack Obama would say this all
the time well they're on the wrong side
of history they're on the right side of
history well history doesn't have sides
there's the moral right there's moral
wrong you can be morally right and
morally wrong but you can't be
historically right and historically
wrong history just comes and goes on the
morning of September 11th 2001 history
was moving in one direction it was a
beautiful day we had peace and
prosperity all over the world and then
that history took a turn that morning
and we learned that history doesn't care
about our ideology doesn't care about
our periods of Perpetual peace that
won't happen
we learned that some people won't go
along with what we tell the whole world
to do and we saw this in the form of
Islamism political islam imperial islam
that sees itself as at odds with the
West not because of anything we did not
because we helped found the State of
Israel in the West not because we helped
this nation in the Middle East over this
nation in the Middle East because of who
we are and what we believe and the
culture that we have and the language
that we speak and the land that we live
in and the freedom that we have in that
land that's what we learned 9/11 was not
the first time that this ideology of
Islamism political Islam tried to
conquer the West it goes back a long way
it goes back all the way to the eighth
century it goes back to the Battle of
Tours in 732 it goes back to the Battle
of Lepanto in 1571 and it goes back to
the Battle of Vienna in 1683 now why
bring up all of this history might seem
like ancient history all of these
incursions of Islamic empires into
Europe to try to conquer Europe being
held back at various points the reason I
bring it up is because history isn't
over history is not alive our history
rather is alive it's not over there's no
end of history the Battle of Vienna was
won by the West on September 11th 1683
this is no coincidence
history isn't over and the terrorists
who planned those attacks knew
their history at Christopher Hitchens
was certain of this Lawrence Wright who
wrote the looming tower won a Pulitzer
Prize for it was certain of that there's
no end of history history matters to
other people around the world and we
can't tell them not to believe in it
because there are two ideas there are
two ideas for the International order
nationalism and globalism the the order
in which independent free nation-states
get to determine their own destiny get
to govern themselves have sovereignty
get to live in their freedom with their
culture in their language and global
Empire global Empire institutions that
date back all the way to antiquity all
the way back to Rome all the way back to
the Holy Roman Empire and also we see
them in super national organizations
today like the United Nations like the
European Union like the International
Criminal Court which John Bolton
beautifully talked about last night
nationalism and globalism we saw that
come into conflict 17 years ago and
we're still debating that we're still
resolving that conflict the 2016
election was in no small part a debate
over nationalism and globalism the
president Trump made that the homework
the center of his foreign policy here's
President Trump talking about it in 2016
Americans must know that we're putting
the American people first again no
country has ever prospered that failed
to put its own interests first both our
friends and our enemies put their
countries above ours we will no longer
surrender this country or its people to
the false song of globalism the
nation-state remains the true foundation
for happiness and harmony I am skeptical
of international unions that tie us up
and bring America down those are your
choices these international super
national organizations that take away
national sovereignty were the
nation-state
this has been a long-standing debate
here in the United States basically
after World War two it seems that all of
the Western world was moving toward this
what has been called the New World Order
the UN the kumbaya everybody gets along
the system of nation-states that we
developed after the Treaty of Westphalia
oh that that's over that's passe we're
in a new world order but it's nothing
but Empire and Empire creates serious
problems how are we going to live is the
United States going to chart its own
course defend its own people defend its
own interests or are we going to be told
what to do and pushed around by various
global interests in 2016 we began to
resolve that question there was a clear
articulation of national sovereignty of
nationalism of putting America first and
the American people voted for that but
Democrats in the left are still fighting
against that even some areas on the
right we have to debate that that was
the question that was raised after the
end of history ended after the end of
the end of history 17 years ago and
we're still debating that now our
National Security Advisor Ambassador
John Bolton laid out this argument so
beautifully yesterday when it comes to
the International Criminal Court
so ambassador Bolton yesterday was at
the Federalist Society he was giving a
major speech on American foreign policy
and he assailed the International
Criminal Court the ICC a lot of people
don't know what the ICC is the ICC is a
relatively new institution it was
founded in 2002 theoretically to
prosecute war criminals the
international we're gonna go in this
super national body is going to go in
and prosecute criminals in various
countries and even if they don't want us
to we're just going to go do it now
early on the United States Russia and
China didn't sign on the Clinton
administration in 1998 made it seem as
though the United States was going to go
along with it
President Bush reversed all of that and
said we're not going to go along with it
largely thanks to John Bolton so in
theory the International Criminal Court
sounds great
in reality all it does is take away
national sovereignty so countries that
are advocating globalism Europe some
aspect but parts of the United States
supports of the American political scene
loved the idea of this John Bolton
realized it was awful here's ambassador
Bolton assailing today on the eve of
September the 11th I want to deliver a
clear and
ambiguous message on behalf of the
President of the United States the
United States will use any means
necessary to protect our citizens and
those of our allies from unjust
prosecution by this illegitimate court
we will not cooperate with the ICC we
will provide no assistance to the ICC
and we certainly will not join the ICC
we will let the ICC die on its own after
all for all intents and purposes the ICC
is already dead to us got a love
ambassador bolt and that man does not
mince words
I think his moustache is made of
titanium I mean that is a seriously
strong hombre so he says the ICC is
already dead to us and of course this
makes sense when you look into the
particulars of it you see how ugly it is
are we really going to agree that the
super national body you know Venezuela
the Democratic Republic of the Congo is
going to tell the United States how to
order our affairs there's no more just
body on earth than the United States
than our criminal justice system if
justice is going to be served anywhere
on earth it's going to be served in the
United States we don't need other
countries telling us how to do it or
what to do and allowing politics to
infect it nlm allowing it to infect our
international system and international
politics one aspect of the International
Criminal Court when it was founded is
that people could be prosecuted for
ecocide ecocide
but it's that it means you attack the
environment you know you you smash a
rock or something you could be brought
up on charges for the International
Criminal Court the reason that john
bolton
was so precise here is because the icc
wants to go after american soldiers they
want to go after american soldiers who
served in afghanistan or iraq and they
want to prosecute them for alleged war
crimes and we are not going to allow
that to happen
ambassador bolton was so clear if you
come after us we're gonna sanction you
we're going to not allow you to enter
the United States this is not going to
end well and at the same time in the
same speech he makes an announcement
that the u.s. is booting out the pl
o--'s office the Palestinians office in
the United States we're kicking them out
because it's illegal here's the
Ambassador Bolton the
Department of State will announce the
closure of the Palestine Liberation
Organization office here in Washington
DC
as President Reagan recognized in this
context the executive has the right to
decide the kind of Foreign Relations if
any the United States will maintain and
the Trump administration will not keep
the office open when the Palestinians
refused to take steps to start direct
and meaningful negotiations with Israel
according to a 1987 law the PLO should
never have had an office there in the
first place and now this administration
is enforcing the law so much of this
administration is about enforcing the
law which is a very important thing
because as we reflect 17 years later as
we reflect and look around the world so
much of what we can do is to simply
enforce the law and keep the order of
nations going and to defend American
national interests because the United
States is the greatest country in the
history of the world we ought to do that
we ought to be a sovereign country
people hate us because of our freedom
but we need to maintain that freedom and
if there's any silver lining that is the
silver lining of that tragic day 17
years ago so we've it's so hard on
September 11th because there there is
just no way to feel good about it you
everyone there's a silver lining to the
storm cloud but there's no way to say
yeah but really it was it was all for
the best oh it was all for the best
you can't say that it was I speak as a
New Yorker and there's a little kid when
it happened it you felt it so viscerally
in New York and then people all you know
virtually everyone in New York knew
somebody who was killed that day or knew
somebody who knew somebody who was
killed that there was related to
somebody and then everyone around the
country after 9/11 even if you weren't
affected directly by that attack on in
New York and Washington you were a lot
of people know servicemen who signed up
to defend the country and it's just a
tough day it's a tough day and you've
got to just sit in that I think and try
to reflect and see if there's there are
lessons for that for how we move forward
but you can't you can't put lipstick on
a pig you can't say that it's a it's a
nice thing it was good for the you know
it was good and we learned something
from it and really you know
all worth it or something in the end it
was a really awful moment for the
country there were some nice things that
we can get out of suffering but it's a
suffering nonetheless suffering can
sanctify but it's still suffering so to
everybody who lost somebody that day
give my condolences and you'll be in our
thoughts and prayers and for people who
sacrificed when overseas fought to
defend our freedom thank you for that
because freedom isn't free and we'll be
back tomorrow and we'll be able to cover
all the craziness in the news in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael nul show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018